hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played in 2001 it was
the uh Corsica Masters rapid tournament
uh and it's a game between Etienne bakra
versus vishana tan Anand it's a game
from round one of the tournament it was
played in bastia France and it's hard to
say how much of this uh game is is all
preparation and how much of it was found
over the board because all of the moves
in the game were kind of played before
like first 16 moves of the game are
known Theory and are still being played
today even though this is uh it's not
the pre-engineera it's sort of the the
middle engine era because even though uh
some players didn't even consider
engines all that impressive back in 2001
some have used them to Great extent and
Vladimir kramnik for example used them
uh much earlier than others and it's
hard to say how early he started
employing um ideas that were maybe based
on an engine moves and uh I don't know
maybe he even used the you used some of
those ideas in His World Chess
Championship match against uh America
Sparrow in 2000 in the year 2000 but
they were not considered unbeatable back
then the engines for example there is
the famous game kasparo versus deep
Fritz from 2003 uh where Kasparov
creates a spectacular positional
Masterpiece against an engine and even
though you could not really accomplish
that many times it was still possible to
do that if you if you haven't seen that
game uh for some reason I will put a
link to it will be the first link in the
description so it's an older video but
the game is still pretty nice so also if
you guys maybe think I should redo it I
I could redo that video it's also pretty
short some eight minutes uh but yeah so
it's it's very hard for me to say uh how
much of it is engine preparation how
much of it is uh known Theory uh without
engine how much of it was found over the
board but what we can say for certain is
that after a certain move in the game
all of the other moves that were made
over the board and uh I even watched an
interview I I think Judith Polgar said
that even in 2002 she didn't really
consider the engines all that impressive
like she knew that some of her opponents
were using engines but when she played
uh some of her attacking moves they just
didn't know how to how to handle that
even though they had a prepared engine
lines for the openings so it's hard to
say but around 2005 uh already you could
say that
you couldn't play against an engine like
even Michael Adams had a had a six game
match against an engine and he was a top
10 10 player back then and he only
achieved half a point out of six games
so it was five and a half uh at the half
in the engine's favor uh but okay let's
dive into the game it comes as a
suggestion from piyush John so thank you
for suggesting such a nice game and it's
a rapid game uh so at the end uh has the
white pieces and he opens with the D4 we
have Knight to F6 C4 E6 Knight to C3 and
of course everyone's favorite the names
of Indian defense with Bishop to B4
Knight to F3 C5 so the three Knights
variation uh pretty much what you would
uh see today G3 now this is the
so-called Romanian casparov system C
captures on D4 Knight captures and here
on under just castles Bishop to G2 and
the D5 now striking in the center we
have C cappers Knight captures and now
Queen to B3 uh Knight to C6 and now
Knight captures in C6 B captors and here
at the end Castle so this is nothing new
this is all still Theory exactly as it's
pretty much being played today and now
Queen to A5 uh putting pressure on the
Knight here on C3 and getting the queen
away from the from the D file also if
needed you will be able to transfer the
queen quickly over to the king side uh
Bishop to D2 and now Bishop captures on
C3 again uh nothing new even in in 2010
uh one beat captures in C3 and now
Bishop to A6 putting pressure on the E2
Pawn but now Rook after D1 again it's a
rapid game and the disc was a known move
back then uh because if you capture now
on E2 then uh C4 opens up an Attack
under the queen and on the Knight here
and even if Bishop captures on D1 grabs
the rook and attacks the White Queen
Queen captures on D1 still the queen is
hanging you have to move the queen queen
A3 C capture C captures and you would
get something like this where white
would have two Bishops for a rook white
would be much better here so instead I
have to Rook after the one Queen to C5
was played and now Pawn to E4 attacking
the Knight and now Knight the B6 uh
Bishop to C4 is considered strongest
today but this is where our good friends
the engines finally uh come into the the
story so here Knight the B6 uh Bishop to
E3 attacks the queen and now Queen to H5
uh and here uh you should go for Bishop
captures and B6 and that's pretty much
it Bishop cat for say captors Queen main
characters we would see something like
Bishop to B5 uh White is up a pawn uh
and uh you know the the game contains
white should be a little bit better but
nothing spectacular uh but here Rook to
D6 was played going after the C6 pawn
and this is not a good move and Anand uh
takes advantage of it he plays Knight to
C4 uh the idea of course is that he just
wants to go after the bishop mess up
white spawn structure and then uh
checkmated the uh the the white king and
if you capture here with real captures
on C6 then you even run into a nice Fork
nice day five attacks the queen and the
Rook so you can't uh grab the pawn right
away and what you should do here it's
very hard to actually make a move but uh
probably go back Queen to D1 it was also
a known move uh and if he got something
like Rook to D3 it's not gonna be much
easier Knights the five again attacks
the rook and once you move the Rook
Knight G4 now now threatens Queen
captures and H2 threatens the bishop on
E3 and after you kick it away just
captures captures on E3 and you've
completely ruined a white skin side it
will be a very easy game for black so
instead after Knight to the C4 we
mentioned that Queen to D1 is is
probably what you should do but Rook
captures on C6 is what Etienne played
and this uh kind of loses the game on
the spot and of course it is now only as
of move 18 that this position has never
been reached again and for good reasons
here Anand played Knight captures on E3
as you might have imagined and now you
should react to this by just accepting
okay uh your Pawn structure is all
messed up you're gonna play locate the
B8 attack the queen queen back to D1 and
now it's a bishop T2 further harasses
the queen black is better here but white
can fight however after this uh Rook
captures an A6 move uh something
completely different happened
Knight wasn't captured on E3 instead it
didn't play the real captures on A6 and
now Anand is completely win winning but
you have to find the very precise line
that aren't played so feel free to pause
the video here and win the game for
Anand while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on solving uh this
beautiful uh well creation dare I say it
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is Rook 8 to B8 uh
such a such a weird move to play in a
situation like this when your knight is
hanging but uh White first must react as
The Queen Is Now attacked even though
the engines is uh this is so bad for
white you should just uh let black have
the queen you should capture the Knight
and then capture The Rook once Rook
captures Queen but okay we're not gonna
play that you have to move the queen and
the problem is Knight covers D1 and C2
so you can play Queen to A4 or queen to
A3 A3 is really bad because Knight C2
just wins a lot of material here so
Queen to A4 was played and now again not
reacting to the Knight being attacked on
E3 Anand goes for this beautiful Rook
lift to Rook the B2 and now it becomes
apparent what Anand had in mind if F
captures an E3 Queen E2 and you cannot
prevent Checkmate either Queen captures
and G2 will be Checkmate or f2h storage
to have to depending on what white plays
so instead after Rook to B2 Rook the E1
was played now threatening to pick up
the Knight with the Rook but even this
doesn't help ATN all that much because
now Anand just plays Queen to E2 so he
doesn't just leave the Knight on three
he also offers a full Queen and it was
in this position on move 21 that Etienne
bakra resigned to the game as there is
nothing more to be done here the problem
is if you capture the queen it's a very
nice Rook to B1 check and now after
Bishop blocks just Rook captures on F1
will be Checkmate as the Knight covers
the G2 Square so instead after Queen T2
you could also consider Rook to F1 the
guard the F2 Pawn but then just Knight
captures an F1 and again F2 is hanging
G2 will be hanging H2 will be hanging
and even if you try to defend Queen D4
look at this Knight back to E3
absolutely beautiful now threatening
check plus Checkmate uh if the pawn
captures then its own a matter of of a
nice uh Queen characters and G2
Checkmate and if the queen captures
again Rook B1 is sufficient to deliver
Checkmate just Queen captures and F1 and
that's all there is to it so yeah Queen
T2 uh at the end resigns in the
spectacular victory for vishwanathan
Anand who takes down Etienne in only 21
move uh and uh that's pretty pretty
brilliant with the black pieces like I
said it's hard to say how much of this
was uh prepared how much of it was found
over the board but what we can
definitely say is that after this uh
Rook captures an A6 movie it's it would
be very very hard to imagine that you
have a rook 8 to B8 followed by Rook B2
prepared at home so very nicely done by
Anand and also if you guys are
interested Anand also won this
tournament quite spectacularly uh this
is these are the final standings so uh
Anand won the tournament two full points
ahead of Alexander chernan six and a
half points as you can see you can see
Joe Lottery with four points in third
diva again with three and a half of
Peter Peter leko with three points I
mean any tournament that you win uh with
more than twice points than Peter leko
uh that is just unimaginable uh I mean
okay uh
it's unimaginable it doesn't matter uh
what kind of a tournament it is uh so
yeah that's the game and and the
standings had a little bit of uh yeah
you know me talking about the engines uh
uh before the actual game so hope you
enjoyed that as well I would like to
thank the animated chemistry textbook
KGB sellers antibody consultants
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here and thank you for watching
and I will see you soon continuing to
check up on your wonderful suggestions
such as this one and whatever else
happens in the Chess World ah thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day